десятка можу стільця на пікет та й kimi
dake по нa тpoce шана і новий реквізит
забастовку вимагаю чипі 2 щити зарплату
а поза стіною політики це експерти б'ють
нас півсфер джо вчіть українську
liqueur не тій аптеці поспішаючи кіски
відмовитися від держави 0 кішки і стукні
лети юридула програма чи доступні ким
за право джона по нато 3 рок
двічі ще пацієнти серце в суди на
мисах виливанням та бронхіальну астму
діабетом траву типу тягнучи за низьку
граничний замовляти може remotely
тибетського що на зазначену доплату
you to pc pet за грізну за словами та
народні депутати з профільного комітету
верховної ради альфа і стефанишин та
знову гурукулі карниза дихайте без
фінансування а пацієнти демона доступних
деяким буду сини затвор джима порядок
реалізації програми ми особистих гарантій
на пірсі кварталу на ступню в уроку
топ то 9000 аптек 7000 лікарів просто
завищена тебе без кішки у національній
служби за значущою потрібно принтер не
дихати на товар по корі укласти і у
води нас дженна завищувала зараз у і
фактично сьогодні міністр його носить
youtube зупинка
народжуємо на колапс матричну складемо
право у що ще typer опозиції було
передано національну службу здоров'я
україна була оброблена з косматою в тому
числа деки видно пакети і залежить від
доступному потвора приклад xmp за позовом
видного пакета напружувалася косово ти
мобільні бригади
я кіберу тести на вигляд за аналізами
напружуватися косово ти доплати магічним
супротивника
рахунки володіння та перрі укладу раніше
битва видно податкова hу ось я не думаю
що на потребі кича подружжя в гори
національна служба здоров'я наша служба
здоров'я подала вигляд по видний проект
постанови доменних втрат здоров'ю шануй
місяць що мовляв цю порядок дену буря
дуться і документи так і не по трапу у
позитивного чорти мауса швидко степанова
винза кади на свою адресу витки та й
обидві ціни та близької години такі троянди
глянути і
до протилежної постанови бюджет бюджетом
на 2025 ширик передачі ночі матиціну
ранок мої фанати 160 мільярдів гривень
ланцюги shiny shoe 2020 алла цифр і
маніпулює владос тверджу ще сцена 42
сотки вбили jiayu позицій що він ще на
20 ще так і зрощення означає нам менше
лише прикладом
на ранок мене офісу президента г путай
сбу
праві по суті ці жебраки манула уроку ви
витрати на охорону здоров'я почалося в
розмірі 100 13 мільярдів гривень пані
на висоті та суму закладання до бюджету
на 2026 60 мільярдів з правді 42 сотки
заощаджень laugh with не будуть хвала не
заміну doors бюджету 2020 іванівну на
борошно штори си у сфері охорони здоров'я
та дол ще 16 мільярдів гривень ворогів
вуйчичу доплату хороший стан та гришиною
на 40 аличе на 22 сотки вона лікарями
адже пацієнтам такий математик in action
медицина дали завищується треба фінансово
ну особливо загляну на пандемію
коронавірусу
вакцинація засіки на достатню брошку
приду бачила для закупівлі вакцин вид
кава 19 самий наш планувати ставку
за kidney країни угу розбивши проти шкоди
вірусом в Україні на вакцинацію
волію душі два з половиною
мільярда гривень за каченям експерт ff2
чим менше непотрібного україна відомого
розривають remote безкоштовно вазі
мільйонів доз вакцин у рамках програми
kovax олег вулиці буде точним і відомим
але того шевчуку буду достатню для
вакцинації понад 4 мільйони українців
готовий чоппер про будь-який активний
імунітет потрібно куб і 1000 найменш
65 wetsuit ким на сьогодні
на цю реформу, а про зраду трьох
міністрів оборони здоров'я президент це
числа npc's пропуску гнутим відмінну
форму вона продовжується з великого до
відео стартувавши друга етапів же на ринку
фтор і на youtube спати або покликати
найму особисту допомогу
поліклініках скільки або кореня патенті
про лігу та стиль гекко поштивіше 3 травня вид
національну службу здоров'я України c
рубль себе, щоб з плакати
поліклініки тануть заклади треба вати
який з не по злості ще пацієнт пішов дме
кроку лікаря рахунок заруби то операцію то
вирішили core i3 мій графік праві скиду
району че місця більше на моєму що
правда кольору помади формою skype з
пандемією у kuro no вірусу
теж його реалізація означає
провалювалася та 2021 покажи chef дай
сюди швидше за мадру форму taking a cheap
застряють і деки політики можна
степанова можна ще повернутий і старий
радянський метод оплати мет послуг через
субвенції так по суті в ручне
управління мінах роль здоров'я